The App Store is especially lit
because Wiz Khalifa is about
to drop his very own mobile game
entitled
Wiz Khalifa's Weed Farm.
-So it's kind of like
Farmville... -On the nose.
-...if your farm had to smell
like Portland, so... -(laughter)
This gives gamers a glimpse
of what it would be like to grow
and sell weed without having
to disappoint their parents.
Take it from Wiz himself,
who says...
(audience jeering)
I'm going to see it
again and again.
Uh, Wiz,
if you wanted to be Pokémon,
why didn't you just make a game
based off Smokémon?
♪ Smoke every day,
weed every day ♪
♪ We smoke weed every day ♪
♪ Every day,
smoke weed every day ♪
♪ Every day. ♪
(whooping, applause)
All the Pokestops
are park benches
wherever you can buy
a gas station hot dog.
Uh, now, since Wiz Khalifa
has gotten the ball rolling,
what will the next
controversial
celebrity video game be?
-Felicia. -Kendall Jenner's
Pepsi Challenge.
(laughter)
(applause, whooping)
There are no winners
in that game.
Points.
Uh, Hampton.
Tyler Perry Presents
A Very Madea Ghost Protocol.
-Yes, points.
-(laughter)
(applause)
Points. Jonah.
Uh, Steve Bannon's Cuck Hunt.
-All right, points! Very good.
-(audience groans)
-Very good.
-DAY: Yeah, that was good.
RAY: That's a high-level
political joke.
-You guys don't get it.
-It's not that high-level.
-No, it's real smart.
-No, you just swapped out
-It's really smart.
-the word "duck" for "cuck."
No, it's-it's okay.
Please, God, don't...
don't take this away from me.